thank you breaking news the rmt the main
transport Workers Union holding a press
conference on National Rail strikes
let's listen in
meaning that we'll be taking continuous
industrial action for more than four
weeks
despite
every effort made by our negotia is is
clear now that the government is
directly interfering
in our attempts to reach a settlement
the union suspended previous strike
action in good faith to allow for
intensive negotiations to resolve the
dispute
yet Network railers failed to make an
improved offer on jobs paying conditions
for our members during the last two
weeks of talks
same time the rail delivery group
representing the train operating
companies has also broken a promise to
make a meaningful offer on pay and
conditions and even canceled
negotiations that were due to take place
yesterday with one hour's notice
we also have have evidence from all 14
of the train operating companies denying
that the rail delivery group has the
authority to conduct negotiations on
their behalf
even as the RDG yesterday
urged us to come back to the table and
develop a deal
we now doubt that either the rail
delivery group or the train operators
themselves actually have the authority
to negotiate a settlement to this
dispute and we have the evidence here
with us the letters that they've written
and that their lawyers have written to
us
The Authority now Six diet sits directly
with the Secretary of State Mark Harper
and he seems intent on blocking any deal
being developed between the parties
I will be taking this up with him at a
meeting that he arranged he has arranged
with me for this Thursday morning
this latest round of strikes will show
how important our members are to the
running of the country and will send a
clear message that we want a good deal
on job security paying conditions for
our people
we have been reasonable but it is
impossible to find a negotiated
settlement when the Dead Hand of the
government is presiding over and
blocking a resolution in these talks
the employers are in disarray and saying
different things to different people
sometimes at the same time
the whole process has become a fast that
only the new secretary of state can now
resolve and I will be calling on him to
act up to his responsibilities this
Thursday
in the meantime our message to the
public is we are sorry to inconvenience
you but we urge you to direct your anger
and frustration at the government and
the railway employers during this latest
phase of action
we call upon all trade unionists in
Britain to take a stand and fight for
better paying conditions in their
respective Industries and we all seek to
coordinate action including strike
action where we can
work in people across our class need a
pay rise and we are determined to win
that for our members in the rmt and we
will support all other workers in their
campaigns and actions thank you very
much Eleanor from previously
[Music]
well we apologize for that we don't want
this disruption our members will lose a
serious amount of money taking this
action and we will do what we can to
support them but it's time for this
government to get serious they have
created this dispute by cutting two
billion pounds worth of funding from the
mainline Railway National Rail they've
also cut two billion from London
transport and we've got disputes there
so they have made those cuts and the
effect of that is that thousands of our
members are under threat of the less of
their a lot of their jobs we have
serious doubts that the services will be
able to be maintained with these Cuts
they're bringing in stringent cuts to
the safety regime on the railway in
order to make the redundancies and
they're going to strip up our terms and
conditions and let's not forget we
haven't had a pay rise most of our
members for three years now and we're
coming to the turn of the Year again
with no deal in place so we're serious
about what we're doing we apologize for
that disruption but really the Secretary
of State rather than sitting on his
hands has got to get down to the serious
business of creating a settlement in
this industry yesterday I was told
directly by the most senior person
working for the train operating
companies that he has been stopped from
offering us a deal even a feel that we
may not like that we could develop he
has been prevented from doing that by
the Department of Transport and it seems
that they are stuck on the idea that
they will continue this dispute into the
new year for whatever reason they've got
so the Public's anger should be at the
government and we hope they have some
sympathy for our members and for all the
other workers in this industry and
across Industries and across the economy
that are struggling to make ends meet
and earn a living in this Society
yeah we're expecting to have serious
impacts the network rail will be doing a
lot of engineering work over that period
they've got a lot of planned closures
they've got a lot of planned blockades
and we expect there to be a very serious
impact through that overtime ban plus
there will be shortages of train crew
and other safety critical grades during
that period so we expect there to be
disruption arising from that overtime
ban otherwise we wouldn't be doing it
we expect it to impact the entire
Railway service
the overtime ban starts on the 18th and
runs through to the second of January
you worry about the public support
prices lots of people suffering at the
moment this coming at Christmas in the
last two years with covert well we are
concerned about the public and their
ability to make their own living we're
concerned about how the public feel
about our disputes but the public have
also made it clear in the pinion poll
after opinion poll that they support us
and they support the other workers in
this economy who are being screwed down
in orders to pay for a crisis that was
not of their making and what you will
see if there's not a square deal on pay
and other matters is a transfer of
wealth from the working people of this
country to the super rich and the people
that will be paying dividends throughout
this economic crisis so that is how
wealth is redistributed and the problem
in this Society it's been redistributed
the wrong way the Ordinary People the
men and women in this country that get
up for work every day are being forced
to transfer their money to the utility
companies and the energy companies and
the super rich it orders to pay for this
crisis and that's not acceptable
everyone in Britain a pay deal and we're
determined to get one for our members
see and with other separate unions and
we will seek to coordinate whenever we
can we've put down our marker and it's
now up to others and there are a whole
series of ballot results coming through
in November and December and even into
January and we will be seeking to
coordinate with any set of workers that
wishes to stand up and fight for their
Futures so we are open to any
discussions with any unions or with the
TUC itself okay how hopefully you for
some sort of progress on Thursday Road
delivery group so they can see the
outline of a deal well if they can see
the outline of a deal you'd wonder why
they canceled the meeting with an hour's
notice yesterday I know what the deal is
my executive committee know what the
outline of a deal is that they want to
propose but they won't make the offer
you can only take an offer in writing
there is no offer in writing and there
hasn't been for six months no offer on
pay no offer on job security and no
written offer on what they want in terms
of what they call modernization so I'm
not hopeful if senior people in the
industry are not allowed to put pen to
paper and sign it and say there's that
our proposed deal I'm not hopeful that
this government will allow any deal in
this industry because they seem on tent
on having disputes with workers all
across every sector of our economy
it's no different in substance there are
some wording changes but substantially
it's a four plus four offer over two
years there's nothing for last year so
it lasts over three years in effect so
it's the same deal in a different bundle
and it's still not acceptable and it
won't be acceptable even if they redress
it half a dozen times
change this substantially no not at all
across the industry literally hundreds
of millions of pounds your action
self-defeated because you're just going
to run it into the ground and end up
strong and then your members well then
it would be cheaper to settle rather
than hold out so what's going on and the
Daily Mail particularly want to pay
attention to this is that every day that
we ever strike the government writes a
check for the train operating company of
30 million pounds that's eight days
already so work that out and it's going
to be eight days more every time we do
that they will transfer taxpayers money
from the government coffers to the
private sector who are all making profit
during all this period and made profit
throughout the pandemic without any
losses being suffered whatsoever so you
would wonder who has got the ideological
uh point in this dispute we believe it's
the government that are transferring all
of our money to private sector uh train
operating companies for no good reason
when they could sponsor a settlement
very quickly and get a reasonable deal
which they won't name so the the
documents they've sent us uh threaten us
with thousands of jobs on one of our
claims is to get a job security
agreement now they're ready to write
that agreement I've seen a version of it
written down for some reason the
Department of Transport stopped that
meeting with 55 minutes notice yesterday
afternoon I don't know why that's
happening perhaps somebody in the in
Fleet Street can find out because what
will happen after this is that the right
wing press will regurgitate every line
that the train operating companies and
the RDG and the government put out
without question so maybe some of these
questions should be put to them why are
they sponsoring a trade dispute costing
millions and millions of taxpayers
pounds
I'm not dragging anything out I'm
determined to get a settlement and we
can get a settlement very quickly even
this week so we will keep campaigning we
will keep striking until we get a set of
proposals that our members can support
in a referendum
right now would they
well I will negotiate with the people
that employ our members and then we'll
talk about that and it will be up to our
members to decide what they want to
accept
what made you decide on these specific
dates obviously you could have caused
more disruptions and get closer to
Christmas we do not want to do that
what we when our business isn't just to
disrupt people's Christmas we're
pursuing an industrial dispute and we
will take the most effective action that
we can to pursue that dispute bearing in
mind what public opinion is like and
that's a difficult thing to to
countenance and what we need to do to
get these companies back to the table so
they've got two or three weeks now
before any action is taken to put
serious proposals on the table it's up
to them whether they want to do that and
avoid all of this action
I calculate that for every Striker the
railway industry has lost five thousand
pounds that's a lot of money to be taken
out of the industry well it's not being
taken out of the industry the company is
dumping taxpayers money back into the
accounts of the train operating
companies they have indemnified them for
every strike we've taken and the train
operating companies themselves have
suffered no losses whatsoever so the
money's not leaving in the industry in
any sense that you might describe Simon
a check is being written by Mark Harper
by Grant chaps and whoever came in
between if you can remember those people
they have written checks directly to
Steve Montgomery
and Andy Meadows who I face at the table
and a bellio and first group and go
ahead group pocket that money and lose
no money whatsoever when we're on strike
so the questions have got to be asked
the other way around we're not taking
the money out of the industry we give up
our wages they don't give up their
dividends or their profits they're
indemnified for every loss that is
incurred through the fare box
well I expect that from from yourself
that's a sort of quality journalism I've
come to expect from your particular dark
corner of Fleek street so you should
call us what you want and you no doubt
you will call us what you want and you
called Mr Mosley one of the finest
things that ever happened as I remember
when you were back in the black shirt so
you can back then you can back us
I'm not the Grinch I'm a trade Union
official and I'm determined to get a
deal
uh we owe it to the passengers to stay
around the table asking the rnt to stay
at the negotiating table yeah it's
hysterical isn't it I had a meeting with
them and I've got an email on my phone
here from Steve Montgomery saying I'm
canceling this meeting on Saturday
morning he rang me personally and said
come to a meeting on Monday I will make
you an offer and you can bring that to
your executive committee on Tuesday and
they're all here waiting for that offer
he phoned me at five past one yesterday
for a two o'clock meeting and said to me
I've had to cancel this meeting I am not
allowed to make you an offer either on
the conditions the job security or the
pay the only people that could have
stopped in making that offer are the
department for transport so they're
calling me back to a table
that they asked me not to go to
yesterday
but why we'll be at the table this
afternoon if they want but they have to
make an offer there's no point to be
sitting around there sharing cups of tea
and biscuits with them if nothing ever
comes out of those meetings we've been
in with them for six months since the
action started and we were in with them
for a year before the ballot started
back in the in the springtime so they've
got to be serious about making proposals
and at the moment we believe they're not
allowed to make those proposals for a
political reason